heureuse selon le gouverneur de la
région de louhans directeur frédéric
leclerc faisait un reportage justement
sur l'évacuation de civils des villes de
severodonezk et de les choses que donc
ces deux villes clés dans la région de
luhansk contre lesquels est dirigé une
grande partie des forces de frappe russe
en ce moment je pense qu'il ya un
problème de voix aussi encore mais je
continue avec vous pour à aiguë
voilà et les ukrainiens ont dit avoir
suspendu ses opérations d'évacuation
pour le moment à cause de cette tragédie
mais c'était clairement on est dans un
endroit où le danger est très grande ce
sont des jeunes qui se font évacuer des
civils et pas tout les jours parce que
parfois les autorités ukrainiennes
disent que c'est trop dangereux
d'évacuer les gens les routes sont
ciblés par les forces russes qui estate
empêcher les ukrainiens doute pouvoir
fournir leurs troupes notamment mais
aussi fournir la population civile
restait sur place on aurait alimentaire
les russes tirs sur les routes qui
mènent à ces villes de lucy zhang et de
severodonetsk que ce qui fait que toute
mission dont cette zone est
particulièrement content dangereuse mais
bien sûr il y à des combats à un peu
partout dans le monde vaste et je pense
que dans le dos de basse aucune question
journalistique ne peut être considéré
comme absolument sans danger et on va
voir en plus de détails émergeront play
jeux pour le moment je n'ai entendu rien
qui laissait supposer que frédéric
leclerc ne respectait pas toutes les
consignes sécuritaires qu'on a pu lui
tout n'est que ce soit à sa rédaction
les soldats ukrainien qui continue où
les humanitaires ukrainien d'ailleurs
aussi qui quand ils accompagnent les
journalistes sont très social toujours
de ce que les consignes de sécurité
soient respectées par tout le monde
merci beaucoup gilbert pour ces éléments
bfm tv affirme que c'était sa deuxième
mission en ukraine et bien sûr nous nous
associons à la peine à la douleur de la
rédaction de bfmtv paris exige de son
côté une enquête transparente après la
mort de frédéric leclerc imhof